the world number one novak djokovic has
not had a covid 19 vaccination but he is
booked to play in the australian open
from the 17th of january according to
immigration rules any non-australians
entering the country must be vaccinated
against covert 19.
djokovic told immigration officials that
he has been infected with kovid twice
that meant he was initially given a
medical exemption from vaccination and
allowed a visa but the whole thing blew
up when djokovic posted this on social
media
many people in australia were angry
particularly given the fact they've
lived through months and months of harsh
lockdown
he wasn't vaccinated so he shouldn't
have been allowed in
the rules should be same for everyone no
matter who you are where you are where
you're coming from rules
are rules
and there are no special cases
and has been our government's strong
border protection policies and
particularly in relation to the pandemic
that has ensured that australia has one
of the lowest death rates from covert
anywhere in the world the tennis star
had his visa cancelled upon arrival in
australia and was sent to this holding
hotel in melbourne the abf can confirm
that mr djokovic failed to provide
appropriate evidence to meet the entry
requirements to australia and visa has
been subsequently cancelled his requests
for a personal chef and access to a
tennis court were rejected he and his
team appealed the visa cancellation and
won after five days in the hotel
[Music]
[Applause]
djokovic's team had provided evidence
that the world's number one had tested
positive for covid on the 16th of
december
this photo then surfaced of djokovic
with young tennis players on the 17th a
day after he tested positive
17
okay so uh
this press conference
is a joint at the moment a leaked letter
from the organizers of the australian
open suggested that players may be able
to obtain a temporary exemption if
they'd recovered from kovid in the past
six months on the course of this journey
as the introduction of medical
exemptions were proceeded with is there
was plenty of contradictory information
plenty of conflicting information
tennis australia said it had not
knowingly misled players and had always
said it was best to get a vaccine we
went on a journey of vaccination for
everyone coming in and actually during
the u.s open only 50 percent of the
playing group was vaccinated and today
it's more than 97
and while all this has been going on
debate has raged around the world
he makes his own decisions and everybody
is
free to take
their
own decisions but then
there are some some consequences
you do have to be vaccinated and
you know it's not like someone should
get special treatment just because of
the status that they hold in serbia
novak djokovic's father accused the
australian government of politicizing
the decisions
rallies and protests were held in
support of novak djokovic and some
supporters were even pepper sprayed on
the streets in melbourne on monday
now novak djokovic is in a waiting game
until the australian open begins